hello nama saya Olivia Lan dan saya adalah penyelidik dan pendidik di IBM Quantum video ini menandakan pelancaran
siri baharu di saluran YouTube Qiskit dan platform pembelajaran kita yang dipanggil Quantum Computing dalam
Praktik ringkasnya dalam siri ini saya akan tunjukkan korang cara menggunakan komputer quantum yang wujud sekarang dengan sepenuhnya
berbilion video dah ada di internet tentang komputer quantum dan potensi masa depannya atau tentang Konsep teori
di sebalik pengiraan Quantum yang juga sama pentingnya tengok understanding Quantum information and computation
yang dihoskan oleh John Watrous sebagai contoh tapi dalam kursus ni kita akan anggap pelajar mungkin tahu sedikit lebih banyak
daripada yang kita ada sebelum ni dan kita akan pergi sangat jauh dari segi teknikal dan itu kerana dalam tahun lepas dan pada
masa rakaman ini ia adalah 2024 kita telah melihat perubahan satu peralihan fasa kalau nak cakap ke era baru
pengiraan komputer quantum akhirnya menghampiri titik di mana ia boleh berguna walaupun bereksperimen dengan
circuit berskala kecil dan komputer quantum adalah perlu untuk mendidik komuniti kita tentang cara menggunakan mesin-mesin ni tiada siapa yang menjalankan eksperimen
yang tidak boleh dilakukan pada komputer klasikal biasa tapi pada hari ini kita telah memasuki era
utiliti quantum dan apa itu utiliti korang mungkin tanya ia berbeza daripada Quantum Advantage yang boleh difahami sebagai
titik di mana komputer quantum mengatasi komputer klasikal pada tugasan yang bermakna sebaliknya utiliti bermaksud
ia boleh mula bersaing antara satu sama lain dan ini adalah langkah semulajadi seterusnya dalam
Evolusi teknologi IBM menerbitkan kertas yang menunjukkan buat pertama kalinya tahun lepas komputer quantum boleh digunakan untuk
mensimulasikan model fizikal dan bersaing dengan teknik simulasi klasikal terkini ia bahkan mengatasi
cubaan brute force dan bagi penyelidik satu jalan baru yang boleh mereka gunakan untuk penyelidikan jadi kenapa ini semua berlaku
sekarang well dalam beberapa bulan lepas IBM telah menjadikan pemproses Quantum lebih 100 qubit tersedia secara meluas kalau korang
dah pengguna korang mungkin perasan kita keluarkan banyak pemproses kita yang lebih kecil untuk bagi laluan kepada cip yang lebih besar ni dan kita rasa ia
benar-benar penting untuk buat tu sebab beberapa bilangan qubit masih boleh disimulasikan secara klasikal tanpa masalah jadi takde
keuntungan sebenar yang boleh diperolehi daripada menggunakan cip ni namun pada 100 qubit ini bukan lagi kasusnya ia tidak boleh
disimulasikan secara klasikal juga penting untuk ambil perhatian bahawa ada benda yang dipanggil simulator yang
pada asasnya adalah program komputer dan ia boleh meniru beberapa tingkah laku sistem quantum termasuk bunyi hingar namun sila
jangan terlepas pandang fakta bahawa saya katakan meniru simulator bukan komputer quantum ia tak boleh menghasilkan hasil yang
boleh dihasilkan komputer quantum pada skala ini tapi ia masih merupakan bahagian penting dalam aliran kerja ujian kita jadi itu adalah jawapan yang sangat
panjang kepada soalan di bahagian atas slaid ini apa itu Quantum Computing dalam amalan dalam kursus ni saya akan ajar korang tentang
kes guna potensi yang realistik untuk Quantum dan amalan terbaik untuk menjalankan dan bereksperimen pada pemproses skala yang lebih besar
ini hari ini jadi siapa yang kursus ini sasarkan jom kita mula dengan menetapkan beberapa tahap
pada permulaannya kursus ini adalah untuk semua orang yang bertujuan membangunkan aplikasi baru untuk komputer quantum nak
tahu cara menskalakan kerja semasa mereka atau belajar cara menggunakan quantum dalam aliran kerja sedia ada mereka saya sebelum ini
menyebut bahawa kursus ini akan sangat hands-on dan kita tidak akan bincangkan aspek teori hampir sebanyak mana kita
jangkakan korang datang dengan pemahaman asas tentang apa itu pengiraan Quantum tapi kalau korang belum sampai ke situ lagi tak pe sila je tengok
beberapa episod pertama kursus John Watrous dan korang akan sedia kita juga nak pastikan orang yang menonton tahu
bahawa ini bukan sahaja kursus untuk ahli fizik atau saintis komputer dua subjek ni memang telah
menguasai Quantum Computing selama sedekad lepas atau lebih kita nak pastikan orang lain yang bekerja dengan data besar atau
simulasi seperti Jurutera ahli kimia dan saintis bahan tahu bahawa kursus ini juga untuk mereka ringkasnya
kursus ini ditujukan kepada penonton yang luas dan kita harap korang akan sertai kita sepenuhnya setelah menyelesaikan kursus ini korang
akan dapat faham cara mencipta dan menjalankan kerja skala utiliti melalui Qiskit runtime termasuk keseluruhan aliran kerja
korang akan dapat faham jenis utama mitigasi ralat dan juga faham kemungkinan kawasan aplikasi dalam jangka masa pendek korang juga akan dapat
laksanakan semua algoritma ni dalam Qiskit dan akhirnya kita jangkakan korang boleh faham bunyi hingar dan cara menanganinya
jadi jom kita mulakan Quantum Computing adalah teknologi baru yang menarik dalam peringkat pembangunan awal tapi ia hanyalah
satu bab dalam kisah pengiraan yang bermula ribuan tahun dahulu saya rasa penting untuk faham
konteks ini sebab ia menjadikan apa yang kita nak capai di sini sedikit lebih intuitif boleh dijangka dan kurang
sci-fi sejak zaman purba kita sebagai manusia telah perlu melakukan pengiraan atau
dengan kata lain memproses maklumat mengikut peraturan dan kekangan tertentu untuk membolehkan
komunikasi pembinaan perdagangan sains dan semua aspek lain kehidupan kita kita telah mencari bantuan dari dunia fizikal
dan melalui penemuan yang bijak kita telah membina peranti untuk membantu kita mengira dahulu kala peranti dibuat
dari kayu tulang tali berikat dan ia menyimpan maklumat dan memudahkan pengiraan jauh berbeza dari cara kita buat sekarang
Peranti Mekanikal yang dibina dari tuas gear dan jentera lain maju dari jam astronomi awal kepada
kalkulator kepada peranti pengiraan canggih seperti penganalisis pembeza yang menyelesaikan persamaan menggunakan roda dan
cakera berputar malah teknologi penulisan telah memainkan peranan penting dalam kisah ini dengan membolehkan orang melakukan pengiraan
yang tidak mungkin dilakukan selain tu bila kita fikirkan tentang komputer hari ini kita cenderung berfikir tentang
komputer digital elektronik tapi ini sebenarnya teknologi yang agak baru komputer digital elektronik
pertama kali dibina pada tahun 1940-an alat pengiraan paling awal yang diketahui adalah Abakus Sumeria
yang pakar fikir dicipta di Babylon pada 2700 hingga 2300 SM itu adalah masa yang
lama dahulu tapi kita semakin memahami lebih banyak tentang alam semulajadi dari Archimedes kepada Euclid kepada
Einstein keperluan kita untuk lebih banyak sumber pengiraan telah meledak hari ini kita ada superkomputer yang
pada asasnya banyak komputer yang sangat berkuasa disambungkan secara selari ia adalah salah satu alat terbaik yang manusia ada untuk
menyelesaikan masalah yang sukar tapi masih ada banyak masalah yang bahkan komputer gergasi ini tidak akan pernah mampu
selesaikan lebih lanjut tentang ini kemudian jadi kita dah tetapkan bahawa manusia telah menggunakan fizik dan alam semulajadi untuk membantu kita mengira
selama ribuan tahun dan untuk membantu kita dalam pencarian kita yang tidak pernah berakhir untuk mengira lebih banyak dan lebih besar korang mungkin dah
WEBVTT
biasa dengan Hukum Moore sebenarnya ia bukan hukum sangat ia adalah pemerhatian bahagian hukum tu agak
jenaka pada pendapat saya bilangan maksimum transistor dalam litar bersepadu pada asasnya cip komputer
dua kali ganda lebih kurang setiap 2 tahun selama 5 dekad lepas atau lebih kita bukan sahaja melihat ini tapi menggunakannya dengan manfaat yang besar
dengan lebih banyak transistor kita boleh lakukan lebih banyak pengiraan lebih cepat ini pada asasnya adalah yang bertanggungjawab untuk
menjadikan komputer semakin berkuasa dan lebih kecil dari masa ke masa namun ada berita buruk Hukum Moore nak mati
pakar tidak bersetuju tentang bila Hukum Moore akan sampai ke penghujungnya tapi ada yang cakap ia dah berlaku walaupun kita mungkin tidak
pasti bila kita akan capai had kita tahu ia pasti akan berlaku sebab beberapa bahagian transistor
tidak boleh dibuat lebih kecil secara fizikal korang tak boleh buat transistor yang lebih kecil daripada atom contohnya ini
tentu saja tidak fizikal kedengarannya pelik tapi itulah had yang kita sebenarnya bekerja dengannya jadi apa
yang akan kita buat buat je berenti dan cakap hey ni la sebaik mungkin tidak manusia tak pernah buat tu nasib baik mekanik
quantum telah masuk ke dalam perbincangan mekanik quantum ditemui pada tahun 1920-an dan sejak itu dunia
tidak pernah sama lagi dan kita boleh habiskan berjam-jam bercakap tentang penemuan revolusioner yang
telah dibuat tapi itu bukan benar-benar fokus kursus ni sebaliknya saya nak jelaskan bahawa kita tahu mekanik
quantum dan Pengiraan dah serasi antara satu sama lain penemuan dan pemahaman tentang alam semulajadi
yang kita pelajari dari mekanik quantum sebahagiannya telah menjadikan komputer moden kita mungkin tanpa mekanik
quantum kita tidak akan faham atau mungkin tidak akan dapat mencipta pemacu keras keadaan pepejal contohnya
Pengiraan Quantum adalah hanya langkah semulajadi seterusnya dalam Evolusi ini
tapi pengiraan tidak wujud dalam vakum maklumat memerlukan medium
maklumat pengiraan memanfaatkan dunia fizikal dan ia juga mempengaruhinya ini meletakkan batasan pada apa yang mungkin secara fizikal tapi memahami alam semulajadi
dan batasan fizikal adalah sebenarnya matlamat fizik sebagai
disiplin jadi dalam satu cara fizik dan pengiraan sentiasa saling berkaitan Ralph Landauer seorang saintis komputer dan
penyelidik IBM menyedari berdekad-dekad lalu bahawa maklumat adalah fizikal dengan kata lain maklumat bukan
entiti abstrak tetapi wujud hanya melalui perwakilan fizikal prinsip Landauer mewujudkan hubungan
antara maklumat dan undang-undang termodinamik tapi sebenarnya ada banyak hubungan antara fizik dan
pengiraan fizik klasikal adalah semua yang kita boleh terokai sehingga baru-baru ini tapi dengan penemuan mekanik
quantum kita kini berada di ambang mampu mencipta cara pengiraan yang sama sekali baru dan ini bagus sebab
komputer klasikal hanya boleh menganggarkan apa yang sebenarnya berlaku di alam semulajadi dan dalam beberapa kes anggaran itu sangat
terhad itu sebab sangat susah untuk mendapatkan mesin yang mengikuti undang-undang fizik klasikal untuk
menganggarkan undang-undang fizik quantum dan alam semulajadi bukan klasikal ia adalah quantum satu analogi yang mungkin membantu korang
faham adalah terowong angin dinamik cecair terkenal sangat susah untuk disimulasikan dan diramal secara matematik
bahkan sesuatu yang biasa seperti kereta yang memandu melalui angin pengilang kereta mendapati bahawa ia sebenarnya
terlalu mahal dan tidak praktikal untuk cuba mensimulasikan interaksi fizikal ini bila mereka mereka bentuk kereta sebaliknya apa
yang mereka buat adalah mencipta terowong literal yang menghembuskan angin melaluinya dan hanya bawa kereta masuk ke dalam terowong
dan tengok prestasinya ini sama dengan apa yang saya maksudkan bila saya kata komputer klasikal hanya secara lemah
menganggarkan alam semulajadi dan kadang-kadang terlalu mahal untuk cuba buat mereka buatnya bukannya mensimulasikan angin
penyelidik hanya mencipta semula ia sama seperti komputer quantum tidak perlu menganggarkan undang-undang alam semulajadi pada
peringkat molekular sebab mereka mengikuti undang-undang tu secara intrinsik mereka tak perlu mensimulasikan apa-apa mereka meniru ia dan
kesukaran yang sama timbul bila kita mensimulasikan bateri atau tindak balas kimia yang membawa kita ke bahagian seterusnya
Quantum Computing untuk apa ia berguna jadi
kenapa kita nak fikirkan tentang menggabungkan mekanik quantum dan Pengiraan well dah ada banyak
masalah yang terlalu sukar terlalu mahal dari segi pengiraan untuk bahkan superkomputer terkini kita selesaikan
mungkin masalah-masalah ini hanya penyelidik yang super fokus tapi impaknya boleh menyentuh semua bahagian
dunia masalah-masalah yang komputer klasikal tersangkut pada ini adalah benda yang kita sebagai Masyarakat semakin
bergantung pada teknologi dan benar-benar peduli seperti kecekapan bateri pemodelan kewangan dan
pengoptimuman dan bahkan cara membina kapal terbang yang lebih baik jadi kenapa beralih ke komputer quantum well kita ada sebab yang sangat baik
untuk fikir ada banyak potensi di sini dan kita boleh buka pintu kepada pengiraan baru yang kini di luar jangkauan bahkan
superkomputer yang paling berkuasa secara teori beberapa algoritma Quantum memberikan kelebihan berbanding
algoritma klasikal terbaik yang mungkin untuk beberapa aplikasi bagi aplikasi lain ada bukti yang semakin banyak bahawa walaupun
dengan beberapa bunyi hingar dan ketidaksempurnaan komputer quantum masih boleh digunakan sebagai alat untuk bersaing dengan penyelesaian brute force klasikal
pada asasnya ia adalah alat baru yang brand new dan kita nak tahu lebih banyak benda keren yang boleh kita buat dengannya tapi kita boleh
juga melihat kepada idea asal Feynman untuknya iaitu menggunakannya untuk faham fizik dan alam semulajadi itu sendiri
lagipun saya dah cakap bahawa alam semulajadi adalah quantum bukan klasikal dan bidang ini sangat kaya menarik dan
pelbagai disiplin ia menghimpunkan fizik sains komputer pemprosesan maklumat dan tentunya kawasan aplikasi tertentu yang kita
mungkin minati namun tidak seperti komputer klasikal tidak semua orang ada komputer quantum di poket mereka
sehingga baru-baru ini kalau korang nak bereksperimen dengan komputer quantum korang terpaksa membina dan menyelenggara
satu sendiri biasanya di makmal bawah tanah yang sedih di universiti atau kemudahan penyelidikan dan percayalah saya tahu tiada lagi
kasusnya namun pada tahun 2016 IBM meletakkan pemproses Quantum pertama di cloud ia hanya mempunyai lima qubit pada masa itu dan
kadar ralat yang agak tinggi tapi itu hanya 8 tahun lalu dan tengok betapa jauhnya kita pergi jadi di mana kita berdiri hari ini
ada banyak persamaan yang boleh dibuat dengan zaman awal komputer moden macam yang saya sebut ini adalah
cabaran yang sangat susah dan hanya dalam 8 tahun lepas komputer quantum menjadi tersedia secara meluas selain daripada
mereka yang bekerja di makmal atau kemudahan terkini tapi dalam lapan tahun lepas tu kita telah buat kemajuan dalam setiap
WEBVTT
bahagian pemproses jauh lebih besar dari segi bilangan qubit gates jauh lebih baik dan kita telah memperkenalkan kaedah
untuk mengurangkan atau mengurangkan ralat yang intrinsik kepada sistem quantum walaupun kita terus maju untuk mencipta
komputer Quantum yang toleran terhadap ralat sekarang korang dan sesiapa sahaja boleh guna salah satu daripada pemproses IBM Quantum yang banyak ni yang
dihoskan di cloud hampir semua daripadanya adalah sistem terbaru terkini dan terhebat dengan lebih 100
qubit tapi bukan hanya saiz pemproses yang penting ini hanya satu metrik yang kita peduli dan
itu masuk akal kan kalau kita ada lebih banyak qubit itu jelas lebih baik dengan syarat peningkatan bilangan qubit
tidak merendahkan prestasi namun ini tidak selalu berlaku kita perlukan lebih banyak qubit berkualiti baik yang tidak mengganggu
antara satu sama lain melalui crosstalk bila kita tak nak mereka cara qubit disambungkan antara satu sama lain juga penting untuk diingat dalam
circuit superconducting adalah satu cabaran untuk cari tahu cara terbaik untuk menyambungkan qubit secara fizikal satu metrik yang sangat penting lagi
adalah kesetiaaan gate qubit dua Gates yang berjalan pada qubit tunggal tidak begitu terdedah kepada ralat gates qubit dua adalah kawasan
kebimbangan yang jauh lebih besar dan biasanya salah satu metrik utama yang kita cari untuk tengok prestasi semakin baik dari masa ke
masa gates qubit dua adalah penting untuk dilakukan dengan betul sebab ia bertanggungjawab untuk mencipta keterjaitan antara qubit
yang merupakan salah satu fenomena fizik yang memberi komputer quantum kuasanya akhir sekali kita cari Kelajuan dan kecekapan
kita perlu pastikan masa yang dihabiskan menjalankan program pada cip quantum dilaksanakan secepat dan secekap
mungkin kita merujuk ketiga-tiga metrik ini bersama-sama sebagai skala kualiti dan
kelajuan semua daripadanya penting untuk meningkatkan prestasi sekarang saya nak tunjukkan korang beberapa plot cepat untuk menyokong apa yang saya telah
katakan tentang bagaimana teknologi itu sendiri benar-benar berkembang dengan cepat bilangan qubit itu sendiri adalah yang paling mudah untuk
difahami saya rasa dan IBM telah menerbitkan peta jalan tentang di mana kita berharap untuk berada dalam beberapa tahun akan datang dari segi bilangan qubit
dan saiz pemproses untuk 2024 bila kita merakam video ini kita betul-betul mengikuti jadual dengan pemproses heron dan Condor seterusnya
kualiti plot ini menunjukkan kadar ralat gate yang menjalin median untuk pemproses IBM Quantum dari masa ke masa ingat
bahawa ini adalah skala log jadi walaupun kemajuan kelihatan samar-samar linear ia sebenarnya jauh lebih pesat dari itu
akhirnya kita ada kelajuan graf ini menunjukkan kemajuan metrik yang kita panggil CLOPS yang bermaksud circuit layer
operations per second secara penting CLOPS merangkumi masa yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan circuit dan pengiraan klasikal masa nyata dan hampir
masa nyata yang diperlukan pada asasnya CLOPS adalah ukuran betapa cepatnya pemproses kita boleh menjalankan circuit tertentu secara
berurutan bertindak sebagai ukuran kelajuan sistem menyeluruh dan menggabungkan Quantum dan klasikal
Pengiraan sekarang pada masa rakaman IBM adalah satu-satunya pembekal cloud Quantum yang menyediakan akses ke mesin
qubit 100 ke atas macam yang saya sebut beberapa slaid lalu 100 qubit atau lebih kurang di situlah simulasi klasikal
mula gagal sepenuhnya jadi kerja berskala besar yang dijalankan pada mesin-mesin ini sering tidak ada kesetaraan klasikal ia tidak
mungkin ada sedikit nuansa dan beberapa tips dan trik yang boleh korang gunakan untuk mensimulasikan beberapa bahagian circuit dan kemudian bahagian lain
secara berasingan tapi secara umumnya kita tahu bahawa lebih kurang pada nombor inilah komputer quantum boleh mula buat benda yang komputer klasikal tak boleh jadi
IBM memutuskan bahawa memberi akses kepada peranti yang lebih besar ini sangat penting bagi komuniti yang lebih luas sebab apa sahaja
yang dilakukan pada peranti yang lebih kecil boleh disimulasikan secara klasikal dan oleh itu ia tidak boleh membawa kepada Quantum Advantage peranti 100 qubit
yang kita ada sekarang masih cacat dan masih berbunyi jadi kita perlu bijak tentang cara kita jalankan kerja dan
circuit pada mereka secara naifnya hanya menulis circuit kita dan menekan shift enter mungkin tidak akan membawa kepada apa-apa
yang menakjubkan tapi sekali lagi ada tips dan trik yang boleh kita laksanakan dan amalan terbaik yang boleh kita ikuti untuk meremas lebih
banyak prestasi daripada peranti-peranti ini yang mudah-mudahan akan membawa kepada Quantum Advantage lebih cepat walaupun kita terus
bekerja dan membina mesin toleran ralat kita juga plot ini menunjukkan kos simulasi
atau jumlah masa yang diperlukan untuk menyelesaikan masalah pada komputer klasikal dan komputer quantum yang dilengkapi dengan mitigasi ralat
dan pembetulan ralat jadi garisan pengiraan klasikal berskala secara eksponen apabila kerumitan circuit
meningkat untuk circuit mudah di sini itu tak penting tapi jelas buruk apabila kerumitan meningkat sebab ini
menjadikan kos simulasi sangat mahal dengan cepat mitigasi ralat berskala lebih baik jadi bila kerumitan
circuit meningkat di sinilah kita nak berada kita kini berada di sini dengan kaedah klasikal dan Quantum lebih kurang setara
antara satu sama lain untuk beberapa aplikasi dan pembetulan ralat mungkin paling disukai dan berskala dengan sangat
baik kita hanya belum sampai ke sana lagi sementara itu kita akan terus fokus pada mitigasi ralat dan mencapai kawasan
utiliti quantum secepat mungkin dan dengan memanfaatkan beberapa skim mitigasi ralat yang akan kita
pelajari dalam siri ini kita bertujuan untuk mencari kawasan aplikasi yang boleh memanfaatkan utiliti quantum sangat segera dan itulah
sebenarnya inti kursus ini kita ada mesin-mesin ini kita fikir ia mampu melakukan penyelidikan yang sangat menarik
jadi macam mana kita gunakannya dalam bahagian terakhir episod ni jom bincang secara ringkas tentang kawasan aplikasi untuk
Quantum Computing dalam amalan ada tiga cabang utama yang kita fikir paling teruja untuk diterokai dan mencari jalan untuk Quantum
utiliti yang pertama adalah mensimulasikan alam semulajadi ini berkaitan dengan mensimulasikan interaksi molekular atau atom dan ini
sangat penting untuk kawasan sains bahan dan kimia dan atas sebab yang kita bincangkan tadi kita fikir komputer
quantum akan jauh lebih baik dalam hal ini berbanding rakan sejawat komputer klasikal mereka seterusnya adalah carian dan
pengoptimuman algoritma utama yang diminati di sini dipanggil QAOA algoritma Quantum klasikal hibrid QAOA menggunakan
komputer klasikal untuk melatih dan mencari parameter optimum untuk Quantum circuit dan kita mudah-mudahan dapat melakukan ini jauh
lebih cekap berbanding komputer mana-mana yang boleh sahaja akhirnya kita ada matematik dan memproses data dengan struktur komputer
quantum sangat bagus dalam mencari struktur dalam data yang bercelaru di mana korang atau saya atau komputer biasa mungkin tidak nampak
apa-apa pembelajaran mesin Quantum menjanjikan dalam bidang ini dan kita bertujuan untuk menggunakannya untuk tugasan seperti pengekstrakan ciri
dan pengecaman corak ini memang masa yang sangat menarik bagi kita yang bekerja dalam
bidang Quantum Computing buat kali pertama dalam sejarah kita boleh mula meneroka kawasan pengiraan yang terletak di luar
Pengiraan klasikal mereka yang menonton ini mungkin akan memainkan peranan yang serupa dengan perintis awal
Pengiraan dan mereka tidak mempunyai gambaran tentang apa yang akan berlaku kemudian T J Watson dari IBM bahkan terkenal berkata dia fikir ada
WEBVTT
pasaran hanya untuk dua atau tiga komputer sahaja dan wow betapa salahnya dia kita
semua adalah perintis awal pengiraan tu tapi dalam bidang baru Quantum Computing ni dan Quantum sering
dikontraskan dengan Pengiraan klasikal sebagai sesuatu yang secara jelas berbeza daripadanya dan sering dalam persaingan dengannya tapi matlamat
saya untuk kuliah pengenalan ini adalah untuk mudah-mudahan meyakinkan korang bahawa dari pandangan mata elang kita boleh melihat Quantum
Computing sebagai hanya bab seterusnya dalam kisah panjang pengiraan ia adalah sifat kita sebagai manusia untuk mencari cara baru untuk
mengira dan memanfaatkan kuasa dunia semulajadi dan mencari tahu apa yang boleh kita lakukan dengannya dan kita telah melakukan ini selama
berabad-abad Quantum Computing menawarkan kita alat baru dalam usaha ini dan terpulang kepada kita untuk temui cara kita boleh memanfaatkan
kuasa yang ditawarkannya kepada kita dalam pelajaran seterusnya dalam siri ini kita akan bercakap sedikit lebih tentang sistem 100 qubit
dan bagi gambaran keseluruhan tentang Qiskit SDK perisian quantum kita dan cara terbaik untuk berinteraksi dengan mesin-mesin ini sekarang terima kasih kerana
menonton dan jumpa lagi